JOHN STOSSEL: Do your
kids have a good teacher?
How do you know?
Maybe the teacher
next door is better.
Maybe there's a better
teacher in another state.
Maybe there's a world's
best teacher, or several.
Wouldn't it be great if your
kids could have that teacher?
Well today, yes you can.
SPEAKER 1: Yay, I got it.
JOHN STOSSEL: These kids are
this excited about a math
website.
SPEAKER 2: It's amazing.
SPEAKER 3: Negative 4
minus 4, and we are done.
SPEAKER 1: It taught
me lot of things.
JOHN STOSSEL: Five years ago,
hedge fund analyst Sal Khan
created videos like these
to tutor his cousin.
SALMAN KHAN: That
worked out well.
So then I started tutoring
her brothers and more cousins,
and all the rest.
And I had to do the same
lecture over and over again.
So I had a friend
who said, hey Sal,
why don't you put some of
your lectures on YouTube?
I decided to give it a shot.
SPEAKER 3: Welcome to this
presentation on basic addition.
JOHN STOSSEL: Soon, thousands
watched his lectures.
SALMAN KHAN: I started
getting letters
from people and
comments on YouTube.
And they're not
like, hey, I think
this kind of might have
helped my math exam.
They're like, I failed
calculus the first time.
I've started
watching the videos,
now I'm acing the class.
JOHN STOSSEL: The YouTube
numbers kept rising,
and he got letters from
the Middle East, Africa.
BILL GATES: What Sal
Khan has done is amazing.
JOHN STOSSEL: Now Khan
is funded by Bill Gates,
and he offers web lectures
on everything from history
to economics to
computer science.
His videos are viewed
millions of times.
SALMAN KHAN: Not only is it
reaching millions of students
right now, but even if, God
forbid, I got hit by a bus
when I walked
outside, it'll still
be able to reach
millions and maybe
eventually billions of students.
JOHN STOSSEL: You just happen
to be good at teaching?
SALMAN KHAN: Well, I'll
take that as a compliment.
JOHN STOSSEL: It
is a compliment.
He's a great teacher.
SPEAKER 3: I hope that helps.
See you in the next video.
SPEAKER 4: It's really
helping us learn a lot more.
JOHN STOSSEL: It's
exciting that he
gets kids so excited about math.
In most parts of life, things
have gotten much better-- cars,
computers, cell phones.
Education?
Not so much.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
You rewind 80 or
90 or 100 years,
and you would have
the local band--
if you had a party, that
was the only gig in town.
JOHN STOSSEL: Each village might
have a storyteller or singer.
SALMAN KHAN: Exactly.
But then once you have
mass media coming out,
then people say, wait.
Why don't we take the best
musician, the best actor,
the best storyteller,
whatever way, and record it?
And put it out on radio, put
it out on records, or whatever?
And I think, in
theory, that could
have happened with
education before.
JOHN STOSSEL: But it hasn't.
Even for basic math,
multiplication tables,
I thought they'd be
using video games.
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah.
JOHN STOSSEL: Why not?
SALMAN KHAN: There's a huge
bureaucracy, most of which
wants to say no to
change the system.
JOHN STOSSEL: It's the
blob, people call it.
SALMAN KHAN: It's the blob.
And it is.
And I think what's fun
from our point of view
is that we are able to reach
students outside of the blob.
JOHN STOSSEL: This
California school district
started using Khan's videos
in fifth grade classrooms.
The teachers were
skeptical, but now they're
impressed at what it
does for the kids.
KAMI THORARDSON: They're
happy to walk in the door
every morning.
They're excited about math.
It isn't, oh, we're doing math.
It's like, oh my gosh, we
have math this morning.
That's great.
SALMAN KHAN: We assume that
most people on their own
don't want to do,
don't want to learn,
or don't want to get
engaged in mathematics.
And--
JOHN STOSSEL: Yeah, they didn't.
SALMAN KHAN: I think
they're just frustrated,
because most of them
are in classrooms
that are not catering to them.
JOHN STOSSEL: At
first, teachers worried
that the online instruction
could replace them.
But--
SANDRA McGONAGLE: I
think it's so wrong,
as my teachers would tell you.
They have taught more math than
they've ever taught before.
JOHN STOSSEL: Now teachers
can tutor kids one on one.
SPEAKER 5: Colleen,
I notice you were
having some issues
with fractions.
SPEAKER 6: You can
go at your own pace.
JOHN STOSSEL: And because kids
can go at their own pace--
KELLY RAFFERTY:
I've got students
who are still working
on easy multiplication.
And then I've got
students who are
working in high school math.
JOHN STOSSEL: Some kids
enjoy Khan's lessons so much,
they study at home.
KELLY RAFFERTY: Some of
them are doing two and three
hours a night at home when
I'm asking for 15 minutes.
SPEAKER 7: When I'm at home
and I have some time, I just
log on, and--
SPEAKER 8: It's way
more fun to do math.
JOHN STOSSEL: So finally,
after all these years of kids
being bored in school and not
learning math, that's over?
SALMAN KHAN: I
think it might be.
JOHN STOSSEL: Hope so.
If it happens, it'll
be thanks to those
of online classes, or
the charter schools,
or other experiments
that break out
of the union-dominated
government monopoly.
Let 1,000 flowers bloom.
It's competition that's
given us better medicine,
transportation,
technology, everything.
Don't our kids deserve that too?
That's our show.